et je suis le frère de votre prince
appelé hier paul petit lui que je dois
lui parler tu tires au service de mon
père qu'il est mort mais tu es vivant
mère qui est un vrai papa c'est moi je
suis vladimir c'est le prince de la
dynastie de riourik car au pôle
d'assassiner oleg n'oublie jamais les
gens ne changent pas j'ai besoin de la
puissance des romains
[Musique]
en moyenne à relâche le monde irait
immédiatement
[Musique]
je mettrai fin à la guerre je veux
obtenir la paix je le jure sous la
mémoire de mon père je ne partirai pas
tant que je n'aurai pas pris votre ville
soyez avec moi
c'est elle que je veux faire ma vie
[Musique]
la place n'est pas ici tu n'es pas un
meeting tu nous porte malheur
sauvez vos vies et votre vie
[Applaudissements]
herrina pour
c'est un bâtard même pas à quoi ça
quelle est la tentative s'était dit
inquiet
[Musique]